Um Step 1 shows the timeline action, the cursor target, and the review result for the Korean tutorial.
Step 2 shows the timeline action, the cursor target, and the review result for the Korean tutorial.
Step 3 shows the timeline action, the cursor target, and the review result for the Korean tutorial.
Um Step 4 shows the timeline action, the cursor target, and the review result for the Korean tutorial.
Step 5 shows the timeline action, the cursor target, and the review result for the Korean tutorial.
Step 6 shows the timeline action, the cursor target, and the review result for the Korean tutorial.
Um Step 7 shows the timeline action, the cursor target, and the review result for the Korean tutorial.
Step 8 shows the timeline action, the cursor target, and the review result for the Korean tutorial.
Step 9 shows the timeline action, the cursor target, and the review result for the Korean tutorial.
Um Step 10 shows the timeline action, the cursor target, and the review result for the Korean tutorial.
Step 11 shows the timeline action, the cursor target, and the review result for the Korean tutorial.
Step 12 shows the timeline action, the cursor target, and the review result for the Korean tutorial.